In a close presidential race,
or a penis-measuring contest,
every inch counts, which is why
Team Trump has been using
some creative measuring.
In September, Donald's doctors
listed him as six-three
when he'd been
previously six-two.
We'd say it was a simple
mistake, but, uh, come on.
Trump's doctor's
a medical professional.
(laughter)
There he is.
Was it Mickey Rourke
in Cast Away?
-Looks like. Nice.
-(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-I've actually...
I'm gonna give you
100 points for that.
Uh, I've been calling him
Spammy Hagar. Uh...
-Uh...
-(laughter)
And now Trump's VP,
the Ghost of Mayonnaise Past,
-seems to be following suit.
-Mm.
At last night's
vice presidential debate,
it was clear
that Tim Kaine, Hillary's VP,
and also the dad on every Disney
Channel show...
-(laughter)
-...was substantially
taller than Mike Pence.
And yet,
when we looked it up online,
Pence is listed as taller
than Kaine! What the (bleep)!
Either Trump
and Pence are lying,
or maybe they just measure
their heights
while standing on the backs
of the poor, but...
-(laughter, groaning)
-It's actually...
(cheers and applause)
...a good political strategy.
Look, comedians,
now that this is a thing,
what other physical attribute
might the candidates lie about
to seem more presidential?
-Bob Saget. -Um, Mike Pence.
A lot of people don't know this.
Mike Pence can make a cucumber
disappear actually
-just by sitting on it.
-HARDWICK: Okay. Points.
-(laughter, applause)
-Points.
Yeah. Rich Eisen.
Pence's hair is actually
that white and not the result
of seeing the ghost
that haunts Trump's toupee.
-HARDWICK: All right. Points.
-(laughter, applause)
Mr. Proops.
They're two old
entitled white guys.
They don't have
to lie about anything.